now we used this result just to verify
what we were on what number we got here
okay but where did this come from where
did that that formula come from we can
verify it we can verify the formula
itself by doing something similar
three stuff up when you said axes if
what I want to make a cylinder of radius
R and a height H okay what kind of shape
what kind of function do I rotate
revolve around the x axis in order to
get that cylinder okay well the height
was right that was the height okay so
what would you think of some nice
typical sort of lower and upper bounds
to give you a height of H it was just a
zero
yeah H so let's start at zero let's go
to some arbitrary class H okay so that's
gonna be my domain then I want to have a
radius R right now my ready seems to so
therefore what that corresponds to is
what this line is the equation alright
so he is going to be y equals of
whatever radius so now if I try to work
out this volume that I get the ball is
gonna be equal to let's try it let's use
this for a fly out the front because
it's a closet
by the way a lot of people forget the
time because they just they focused on
the integration from zero to H now
what's why Swain is good it's a scam
good and it's just the constant isn't it
what's that equal to when I actually
evaluate this
what's my primitive it's just I squared
is a constant so it just comes out the
front from 0 into H so therefore I've
got PI R squared H minus 0 there's so
now hopefully this purse is starting to
gain your trust a little bit right where
else can we use it what other clients of
shapes can we make via solids of
revolution yeah
how about currents we'll get to Spees
well I'd like to get a codes first
because Koreans are very very similar
facilities one thing okay now for
yourself of the new same answers how am
I gonna do this what shape ought I to
revolve around the x axis in logic
I don't want to be teased right right so
it's my clone if I want to grow the way
that it kind of does and I'm turning
sideways to begin you know I'm
undertaking this way then that there is
a constant gradient there's a cluster
beanie and it's gonna pass through the
origin
right sorry what should we put here well
I've got some kind of linear function
now I want a radius R and a hyphen H
right so I'll do it like a 14-0 to H and
this here this should be armed now
before it's really easy to work out what
the equation of this was it's just my
beam radius so it passes through the
origin right so it's gonna get in for
white and X what's the gradient its rise
over run yes sir
rise over run gives me okay what let's
give it a go then all you apparently
should be able to play out the foot 0h
is that okay - sleepy it's not okay
because it's Y square okay so remember I
said people forget pie the second thing
people forget used to swear okay so this
really is all square okay good stay with
us now this is going to become a square
H squared X square
I don't know H they're constants that we
just decide I want it to be this wide
this time okay so I'm going to pull them
out the front PI H squared that leaves
me with an x squared inside okay so
someone tell me please what's the
integral now this is interesting cause I
oh I've got an H cubed I wasn't
expecting an HQ because I know what the
boy looks like oh yeah okay so we're
thinking of this shape right there's my
cone okay let's evaluate it till we get
this is PI R squared on H squared H cube
one three ones yep
okay sure H's are gonna cancel how many
you're gonna cancel all of these is one
of him right therefore there's that
third which you're so familiar with okay
yeah okay there's one more shape we
ought to do what should we do we should
do this guy okay I don't know maybe they
ran out of plastic or something I don't
know like so small but now if we if we
want to see on right what shape should I
roll or a semicircle now interesting
enough which one should we do all that
you have a think about that for a second
I'm going to draw so far all we've been
rotating is this one at the top yeah and
that's worked for us fine okay so let's
just consider let's just consider it's
hot hot what is the equation
yeah okay so in this case my radius is
off right so I'm gonna get R squared
minus
that okay all right now what's the
volume when I rotate this thing around
get get the shape okay it's gonna be
play out the front now where am i
integrating for real in a second but I'm
doing the whole body okay now what do I
do next what's next in the formula it's
Y square isn't it so as it happens it
doesn't matter whether you take a circle
or a semicircle because you'll get the
circle back anyway so this is R squared
minus x squared DX
okay now as you will notice this guy is
and it's not just any function it's an
even function right so I might as well
have my work by doubling interval
even okay everyone cases mom yes
cool let's get to five
what's my integral okay from zero to R
okay now at this point it's like boom is
it really gonna come out evaluate is
what happens have we fallen angel
correctly
okay what happens you stick your are in
and you're gonna get a huge minus R
cubed on three minus one is equal to
zero so what's that equal to one one at
that - a third of it is 2/3 2/3 is that
is 3 2 pi 2 R squared
on 3 and sorry to the right are cute I
knew something was wrong
well that's a relief isn't it so so this
idea right that I can take a function
right and instead of working out an area
huh I can work out evolving by going PI
R squared right it's really really
powerful there's lots of different kinds
of elders you give simple ones and ones
wait you already the results but we got
to leave that ok this is basically four
different lions and ones that we so we
have excess